hallo mein name ist bekommt ich war mal
ein kind allerdings war ich nicht wie
jedes andere kind sondern habe relativ
früh mit youtube videos angefangen sehr
früh deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
mache heute mal ein kleines und schaue
mir eines meiner ersten videos an und
lese erstmal darunter ein paar
kommentare vor wir fangen an mit den
mädels kommentaren und zwar kamen also
was die deine stimme richtig süß so
niedlich oder deine stimme so süß oder
süße stimme schauen wir uns jetzt mal
die jungs kommentare an alter wie
altbacken die damals erklingt noch sowie
ein milchbubi aus der grundschule
lifesize passt der lp schreibt komische
stimme du mir leid aber der beste
kommentar und danach schauen uns auch
endlich das video an wie du sprichst du
aus frage da dieser einen frage zeigen
genauso wie sein ich möchte aber heute
gar nicht den fokus auf das dings liegen
auf die kommentare sondern lieber darauf
dass ich oder wollt ihr noch mehr
kommentare wir schauen uns jetzt mein
erstes eines meiner ersten videos an
let's go das sind als sühne mucke in dem
ort geht es darum dass ihr kleiner
ausgleich geschaffen die figuren machen
könnte und die dann ihr alter dem ihr
unten claim-block bereitet und hat ich
lebte er echt wie seine richtige
missgeburt einfach drei dealer ein wlan
danke luca roth einen roten zeigt uns
auch noch mal was man bei blaubeuren
schon grün bekommt und dann habe ich
jetzt schon eine kleine arena ich hab's
aber perfekt vorbereitet eigentlich oder
man mehr ich habe ahnung von der
modifikation und dann kämpfen
gegeneinander kämpfen das rechtlich
nicht 50 euro auf den gelben und wie
mainz genau sie wolle das finde ich süß
sieht er aus wie ein footballspieler
weil jetzt da diese weißen streifen hat
wahrscheinlich den footballspieler oder
alter dass er und pass war damals
richtig vorbereitet kommt reviews wir
mittlerweile nehme ich dir einfach nur
noch auf welche version minecraft sagen
dass 0.00
null was wenn ich ihm allerdings wird
zucker dahin werfen kann sein dass ich
diesen kleinen knaben irgendwie alles zu
werfen kann und damit irgendwas was
anfang an camcorder hinwerfe ihr team
auch grant oder hin wahrscheinlich man
allerdings noch kraft kann ist was man
allerdings noch craften kann richtiger
christoph krachten alter nehmen die item
sogar so aus dem inventar das heißt es
gibt gar nicht diese rausnehmen
funktionen vor wie sie herzlich ein
eigenes kleines kärtchen sucht ja der
leader hat gewonnen
egal ob er richtig ahnung von den ganzen
crafting in den menschen kommt er sogar
was raus alter was sind da viele leute
alter kommen jetzt drückt
alle tore und alle clay soldaten sind
tot das waren jetzt schon alle sachen
die es in diesem motto gibt macht sich
daraus noch auch noch ganze arenen mehr
gibt es nicht ein knopfdruck in die tore
auf in die kämpfen alle gegnern das
war's dann würde ich an der kleine deal
eine tüte uns über einen daumen hoch
freuen einer halle die kleine ich mir
lieber wenn ihr fragen habt dann
schreibt hier ja unter das video einen
kommentar der downloadlink ist denn der
wirklichkeit eine frage und ich würde
sagen es ist wie so was hatte ich dafür
eine stimme okay dass videos jetzt
vorbei ich muss sagen ich kann den
leuten nur zustimmen die geschrieben
haben
es sei nicht der besteht ein milchbubi
aus der grundschule nebenan war gerade
die ganze zeit beim nachbarn ihm die
sonne
stoppuhr oder saniert die ganze zeit
getickt und jetzt gerade aufgehört ja
freunde das war's dann auch schon wieder
mit dem heutigen den tag am mittwoch
sind wir sogar schon nice ich bin wieder
am hsv produzieren weil ich über die
heißen tage wegfahre und ich würde sagen
es euch gefallen haben eventuell oft
dass man so was wolltest dich mal alte
videos anschauen mainau gejuckt wie
scheiße zeigt es mit einer bewertung
schreibt mir die kommentare seit wann
ihm ein abonnent seit das war echt ein
ganz neues zu wissen